apparently james gunn is really upset
about it too
so is denis we haven't heard word yet
from lin-manuel miranda oh he'll be
there he'll have a rap about it
he'll have a whole piece that'll go
viral about it max is not doing
good afternoon reject nation thanks for
being here
if you follow movie news i'm sure you've
heard
christopher nolan's pissed off he's
about as
pissed as we imagined except a little
bit more vocal
a lot more vocal warner brothers is
filing a restraining order against him
he is just so infuriated
we are never gonna get that tenant
sequel he's chained himself to the
studio gate he refuses to leave or to
eat anything other than pure celluloid
until something is done about this
oh man well he interrupted my tenant
sequel joke i was gonna do
that's why i said let me handle the
intro it was a long pause i was like oh
the intro must be done i guess
timing i should have waited that's why i
rush when i talk because you started you
know going wrong damn it now i'm going
to make sure to wait like the full
house like when you're supposed to stop
at a stop sign where you take like three
seconds and you make sure the car like
jiggers first before you move again you
guys are not gonna hear the tenet
sequel joke it was okay it was it was
just that it's the same movie but
everything that was in
reverse is now forward and everything
that is forward is now in reverse but it
was all about the delivery and the
timing and how you said it all right
it's done it's done we gotta move
on to better things look there's a lot
of news coming out here
about hbo max man remember when hbo max
first launched and how
crappy of a service it was so crappy and
then and then they get the snyder cut
and the snyder cut was like oh my god
hbmx
cares about the fans and then on the
other side
warner brothers had the only really good
con
this year dc fandom so warner brothers
hbo max they were killing it
and then they end the year with hey the
people
the people of the world you've been
wanting new movies the big movies you've
been anticipating
well guess what it's all going on hbo
max 2021
and in select theaters and most you're
going to go to hbo max anyway
because 18t rules us now and they make
more money actually
they're worth a lot more money they're
at the top of
a lot of pyramids man you know it's like
as we expected and christopher nolan
he's upset about this but then to come
to find out it's not just
nolan who's man it's a lot of people who
are actually upset now before we go into
this i just want to say
we've been hearing that word streaming
wars for years
now and it's been like little fights
here and there
but no one it's been like netflix is
still king they're still on top even
though they're broke they're still on
top
you know that's that's been them you can
you can talk you don't have to worry
about not talking now i can see what's
going on
i'm just making sure i got an in i'm
waiting for the end
i want to like knock you down all right
mine scrubber there's been some
competition here or there this to me
we have really entered the streaming
wars
this is the war because it's not just
with these
rich companies and people fighting with
each other now
it's the audience the audiences some of
these audiences are like
we look like when hbo max announces how
hyped
were majority of you not everyone i'm
talking about
majority of you guys you saw that list
of movies
a bunch at least two or three things
i've been looking forward to all year
will be on my tv soon
exactly we were all really happy the
stocks went up and then of course it's
put some other streaming services that
worry about competition and
and things like that and they're all
panicking and hbo backs getting
catapulted oh my god this is huge
this changes everything theater's dying
this is the streaming wars
and then now we have filmmakers who are
upset supposedly
they didn't like we're going to give you
guys the nuts and bolts version of
everything all right
like we're not going to do a 45-minute
breakdown video because
this kind of topic can be that kind of
video i mean yeah you can inside
baseball this for hours
you really can like there's so much
mechanisms here apparently legendary
pitchers who uh
financed because you know there's like
distribution then there's financing
there's all these different areas to
doing business and movies legendary
pitchers
finance godzilla versus kong and dune
and apparently
they were not informed about this deal
and apparently godzilla versus kong had
a netflix deal
had a potential netflix offer over 250
million dollar buyout for the film which
would have made them their money back so
they wouldn't have anything to worry
about
yeah so they weren't afforded about this
deal and then also
this is actually what surprised me and
this is what nolan is pissed off about
before we go into nolan's quote i do
want to say that this really is not
about like what we're talking about now
i'm talking about good working
relationships business and long-term
things that could have
that could occur in terms of
partnerships and such
not just how we would prefer to see a
movie yeah because 2021 looks cool now
on hbo max with all these movies coming
out but there's
long-term repercussions that could
happen from this so we have to read his
quote because
honestly i immediately assume when i saw
christopher nolan trending
that uh here we go he's mad about the
theater experience meant to be seen on
the big screen ah
and this is not about that and i think
he makes some really valid points i
agree with him
warner brothers is being a [ __ ] some of
our industry's biggest filmmakers and
most important movie stars
went to bed the night before thinking
they were working for the greatest movie
studio and work
uh woke up to find that they were
working for the worst
streaming service that's a burn
warner brothers had an incredible
machine for getting a filmmaker's work
out there both in theaters
and in the home and they are dismantling
it as we speak
they don't even understand what they're
losing their decision makes no economic
sense and even the most casual wall
street investor can see
the difference between disruption and
dysfunction
it's a unilateral decision that the
studio took they didn't even tell the
people involved
which is not the first time i've heard
this actually you have these great
filmmakers who worked with passion and
diligence for years on projects that are
intended to be
feature films with fantastic movie stars
they've all been told now
that their lost leader that they're a
loss leader for a fledgling streaming
service i've never seen everybody
so upset about one particular decision
it's not right
and it's not a good business decision
it's all a bit
of a [ __ ] move apparently
james gunn is really upset about it too
so is denis villani we haven't heard
word yet
from lin-manuel miranda oh he'll be
there he'll have a rap about it
he'll have a whole piece that'll go
viral about it max is not throwing away
my
shot exactly
but that's the thing is like this is i'm
surprised they didn't learn from trolls
world tour on this because this is
exactly what happened to the filmmakers
involved with that
movie from what i've heard is they woke
up to like delusions of people being
like
what the heck why would you agree to
something like this and them being
completely bewildered like we had no
idea they were gonna do this and it
seemed like warner's didn't take any
notes from
that scenario i mean this is this is on
a cataclysmic
level though because you have a lot of
respectable
people in front of the camera and behind
the camera
and then like you're legendary like the
person who put up the money for your
movie
this is a dick move this is a real dick
move like i said of course people are
going to chime in right away and being
like
what are you expecting to do right now
theaters aren't open i get that
i do that doesn't disregard the fact
that it was
completely messed up that they did not
communicate you have working
relationships
yeah like with with patty jenkins and
gal gadot they got a buy out it was i
think it was based on the fact of if
okay let's say this we made a billion
dollars here's what you would earn
after that and so they got a buyout for
that nobody else apparently did
they just like screw you guys we're just
gonna put this all in hbo max
because we know if we consult you you'll
say no it really seems that's what it
seemed like
you just didn't know if we came to you
so we had to just make the decision it
seems like they treated those like two
completely isolated incidents like we'll
do wonder woman and
then we're gonna come up with this whole
other plan and we're gonna really play
that one by ear because if you look in
that hbo max commercial they put out it
says all the release dates are subject
to change
so none of these movies have to come out
and i'm sure that they have some aspect
of wanting to see
what the response is because not every
version of a straight to streaming when
it was supposed to have a big premiere
has worked so
yeah it does seem like a completely it
seems like the kind of situation yeah
you would want to at least prep
all of your creative teams for because
how could you not expect a mess to
happen after this you got
ray fisher like who's already like one
of the most outspoken people in movie
news right now
around one of your biggest properties it
seems like you would want to
at least consider as many of your
creatives as possible
warner brothers has been such an up and
down year for them in terms of just
everything that comes out with them from
like ray fisher joss whedon oh johnny
tap
amber heard like everything is just all
over the place with these guys
this though this could lead to serious
repercussions because the filmmakers
i think it was new york times i reported
this that they
were the director the dga director's
guild of america is considering
boycotting um warner brothers because
it's not just the directors now it's
also the agents like everyone who stands
to profit and make
money off of this they're all very much
infuriated as as they're rightfully
allowed to be
they're allowed to be upset about this
like i said i got to keep reiterating
this
it's not about whether or not you want
this at home they could have still
landed on that deal
with most of these movies and most of
these filmmakers if they could have
agreed to some type of
payment compensation the way they
handled wonder woman 1984
but the fact that they didn't do that it
just seems like just really messed up
business
well yeah and it reminds me of what
happened with dave chappelle just
recently i mean look at
i mean he spoke to netflix but also a
lot of people jumped on that bandwagon
of don't watch the chappelle show until
it's available in the proper way and he
brought that up in the you know viral
clip that came out of
is it on the contract that they can do
whatever they want is it the right thing
to do
no and this is exactly that situation to
me is
it's not show friends john it's show
business that's right exactly so throw
my mistake
[Music]
it just seems like this is speculation
there's something about
the d what happened with hbo max just
recently of how it seems like they found
like a
loophole like some some type of loophole
where they could win this in court
otherwise i don't think they would have
gone through with it and how and why i
also think
this adds on to the real element of the
streaming wars is because
hbo max does this audiences are really
enthusiastic
the people who worked on the movies are
not enthusiastic about this
most of the audience doesn't give a [ __ ]
so the audience is like well
what are you else like that they're not
going to take the time to really
understand
all of this and they're not going to
really care yeah they're just going to
go well i got my movies i want my movie
yeah if they don't want to make the next
one someone else
screw christopher nolan was being a dick
about it yeah
that's where a lot of this is just going
to get chalked up to and that's where
the
the chaos of the business financial side
comes into play is because hbo max has
won the audience but they don't but the
thing is in order to keep that audience
coming
you need the filmmakers and the actors
involved who want to work with hbo max
and warner brothers to keep moving
forward so this is where the conundrum
all
all comes into chaos this is a bad
situation for them
well yeah i mean to me this is what the
streaming wars is really revealing
itself to mean is it's not
which service is going to have the best
programming it's more like what is this
gonna do to the relationship between
studios
filmmakers outlets that exhibit or
stream these things like it seems like
it's causing a ruckus for
everyone involved yeah and i feel like
that's the true nature of the streaming
wars right now is
just how do we in a time where live
exhibition is so tenuous
do this in a way that's ethical and that
honors the arrangements we made these
films
under because those aren't moot just
because this situation
calls for new circumstances you know all
right guys well
where do you stand on the matter do you
agree with christopher nolan
we're gonna keep following this news as
i'm sure a lot of people are hey
subscribe to real rejects i almost said
christopher nolan uh click that
notification bell hit that like button
if you enjoyed our video
last but not least
adelia chamberlain john specifically
wanted to shout your fine ass out so
take it away john
that's right adelia if there's anyone i
know when i think of someone who has a
fiery moral compass who stands for what
is right
in this world who has a beautiful way of
expressing and engaging
with those ideas so as to bring people
into them
and to create dialogues no one's ever
said something nice it's you adelia
it's you you have a unique ability to
bring that passion you have for life and
the right living
and bringing that to the people and it
inspires us i know it inspires greg
especially because he's got a long way
to go in that department if you know
what i mean but not you adelia not you
at all
so thank you for the love for the
inspiration
for your continued support and just keep
being you keep standing for what's
the right thing we love you
yeah i love you